foreign
nineteen
I stood in Wonder at the end of a
gleaming new electric vehicle Factory in
an industrial district on the outskirts
of Shanghai
I've been working there for six months
as part of an American company's efforts
to launch its first International
Factory and our efforts were about to
pay off
underneath the bright lights and
background din emanating from the
combined efforts of thousands of workers
and hundreds of machines
the first cars were rolling off the
factory line and onto wading trucks
everything around me as far as the eye
could see had been built from scratch
over the course of just a few short
months and the smell of wet paint and
Diesel still hung in the air combined
with rubber and that distinct new car
smell
it was alive and not just for our
company
outside investment was coming into the
district every single day
two lane highways were being Whited into
four and high-rise Apartments were
creeping up into the sky everyone seemed
like they were perpetually in motion
after the project finished I came back
to the States
it was the height of the pandemic and I
was living with my family in rural South
Carolina
the contrast could not have been bigger
where Shanghai was a movie played in
Fast Forward South Carolina was in a
deep freeze
here nestled an hour away from each of
the three nearest interstate highways
there was no Factory no assembly line
no workers
instead on each of the three major roads
headed out of town there was the almost
silent rustle of vines and Moss creeping
up the sides of paper mills steel plants
and other buildings where the last
lights had been turned out decades ago
it was a huge contrast
and I thought to myself why
on the surface the answer seemed obvious
globalization Outsourcing cost cutting
automation there were a seemingly
endless number of terms used to describe
the hollowing out of industrial Parts in
the U.S
and although these terms were useful
they hid the stories of the individual
they had stories behind statistics and
decisions behind Dogma
so instead of talking about the abstract
I want to hone in on the concrete
you see globalization is nothing more
than the sum of thousands of decisions
made every single day by people and
corporations around the world
so if we can think about the human
effects that go into each of these
individual decisions
we can start to influence them and by
starting to influence these decisions we
can start to shape the big picture
trends of these abstract terms
so how do we do that
well here in business school the way
that we're taught to think about
decisions is first and foremost through
models
models are wonderful tools they let us
take a set of inputs apply some
equations to them and get to a really
neat numerical output that you can then
take to justify in any kind of business
meeting
but models only capture the first order
quantifiable effects that go into
business decisions
they leave out the unquantifiable and
the human effects of decisions
no model could have captured the bustle
that I felt in Shanghai or the Silence
of shutter doors in South Carolina
so instead of deferring solely to models
I urge you all to leave room for the
unquantifiable the human effects of the
decisions that we'll make throughout our
careers
to give you an example of what I'm
talking about let me take you back in
time
in 1836 the Western and Atlantic
railroad was building a rail line
connecting the southeast of the United
States to the Midwest
a U.S army engineer evaluating solely
the geographic suitability of the land
identified a site in Northern Georgia
where a stake was driven into the ground
over the course of a couple of years as
the rail line was built a small trading
settlement sprung up and people came
through boarding the train to
Chattanooga and cities Beyond
over the course of years this town grew
and grew and after a while its growth
wasn't tied to the railroad anymore it
was a snowball effect of the people and
the companies and businesses that had
set up shop there
that town grew and grew over hundreds of
years and today it's the de facto
capital of the American South its name
is Atlanta Georgia
Atlanta's growth is the result of the
unpredictable effects that arise from a
singular catalyst
countless contributions to society made
by Atlanta residents Coca-Cola hip-hop
music Delta CNN
these were all through
you can trace these all from twists and
turns to that one stake in the ground
and there are countless of other
inventions the Internet Interstate
Highway System High-Speed Rail social
media none of the creators of these
products could have predicted the
effects that they would have on society
and none of these effects could have
been modeled in a pro forma spreadsheet
I saw the effect of these effects every
single day when I was working on that
assembly line in Shanghai
I would go out to the line and talk to
those assembly workers
many of them had moved from a different
Province to take the job
some of them were using the extra money
they earned to pay for family medical
bills others still were putting their
kids through after school programs in
the hopes that they would one day live a
better life than they did
each of these stories was unique and it
taught me an important lesson
you see the geopolitics of globalization
and the abstract economic theory that we
learn in Business School
they aggregate a bunch of stories into a
single narrative
but sometimes the context that we need
is in the individual
now if investment in a place can lead to
this kind of positive unpredictable
change lack of investment in a place can
do just the opposite
in the U.S since the 1980s the loss of
manufacturing jobs has hollowed out
large swaths of the country
the vines that I saw growing up
factories in South Carolina have spread
like wildfire to hundreds of towns
Across the Nation
in these places the loss of jobs and
ensuing population flight has led to
generational poverty drug abuse and an
increasingly poor quality of life to the
residents who weren't able to move
these effects
could never have been predicted by
quantitative models that looked just at
the first order cost of goods sold for a
business
now perhaps the difficulty of predicting
these changes is why these techniques
aren't taught that much in Business
School
it's really hard without giving a
numerical answer to say how a decision
is going to affect a community or
communities
but just because it's hard doesn't mean
that we shouldn't try and do it
now recently some signs have indicated
that change is on the horizon
last year the U.S Congress passed
several bills the bipartisan
infrastructure Bill the chips act the
inflation reduction act and several more
that have collectively contributed
billions of dollars in federal money to
focus on the unquantifiable
they subsidize domestic manufacturing
and Technology development
in South Carolina many new Factory
projects have been announced as a result
of this investment BMW is building a new
battery plant a carbon fiber Factory
opened just down the street from my
parents house
and with any luck more projects will
continue to roll through to tear down
those fines and open once closed doors
but if I'm being honest
legislation is only the first step
you see the legislation changes
Financial incentives but those only
affect the inputs and outputs of
financial models it doesn't change the
instinct to gloss over anything that
can't fit neatly on a spreadsheet that's
going to happen through time and through
changing our Collective approach
and that's where you all come in
you all will soon be Investors Business
Leaders and entrepreneurs
you'll be faced with these kinds of
difficult decisions
when you are I ask that you take the
unquantifiable into account
think about whether you can plant the
seed that results in unpredictable
change
think about whether you can touch the
lives of families or tear down the vines
that are growing over once vibrant towns
it's not always going to be easy your
decisions will have trade-offs
you might make one Community better off
at the expense of another and you won't
be able to make everybody happy
but with that framework in mind I know
that whatever decision you make
will ultimately be a better one for this
world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]